foreign
[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to the lobby
game spots weekly video game hangout i'm
mike mccarty your host here in san
francisco california i'm here with
reviews editor pete brown hey how you
doing all right i'm all right yeah my
first day back in the office i've been
home sick for a couple days are you
still sick
please find out hesitation
that i'm not intense i'm not feeling 100
but i'm i'm good for the show callie's
also sick yeah kelly plaggy you're sick
too yeah
i didn't stay home though
good luck you're flanking me with
diseases i'm throwing me under the bus
oh i didn't stay home
i i didn't i was really busy one of you
was a one of you was a slacker and one
of you was
infecting everyone
office you're both yeah i think on my
list right now i'm the [ __ ] so cool
i'm putting words in our mouth uh i uh
we have a cool show coming up uh
different format than we usually do uh
especially in relation to neo the newest
game out today our review should be up
soon uh miguel concepcion editor uh was
cranking through like 85 hours of it or
something that's what he ended up as uh
yeah i'm almost there i'm at like three
we're uh
yeah the review's getting the finishing
touches put on it the text in the video
so it should be soon yeah so we're gonna
switch up how we uh talk about reviews
kind of going for in the lobby uh
starting with today see how we uh think
obviously as always we have the youtube
and twitch chats right here in front of
us you are essentially just right on the
other side of the table from me uh yes i
do feel oh that's nick margarita
first person i call out uh is nick
margarita he's on twitch chat but uh
yeah we do have a few housekeeping
things to get through before i get to
our segments first off we have a
giveaway as always we're trying to do
one a week we have the hitman collectors
edition hit me um the full season now
that season one came out last year um
can you hold this there's no one camera
on me um
this is uh the contents of it are very
lightweight there's a statue yeah
there's not in this so we do have one
copy for each platform ps4 xbox one pc
uh we have obviously the statue like
this right here there's a statue of this
with agent 47 sitting on it there is an
art book there is a red tie with the
clip the hitman logo clip um is there a
side that shows all this stuff you
betcha mike oh this makes it way easier
uh the art book as per uge full game
download full season uh yeah so uh
pretty much right now game spots gonna
be tweeting
uh about this and then if you follow
gamespot and retweet nice thank you
talent you can uh we'll pick you later
on the week also let us know which
platform you want it for because like i
said ps4 xbox one
and uh pc and there if you're in the
twitch chat then you can see that uh
shiva just posted it uh twitter status
so uh yeah follow us retweet that and
hopefully you win that later in the week
and i'll get back to the end the show as
a reminder do i have to hold this up the
whole time yes god damn it
no i'll take it okay thank god
so with that out of the way
i do have a few more uh smaller news
stories want to get through
why are you looking at me because i
sometimes pick these just to
get things riled up yeah exactly uh
first off i just thought this one was
funny kojima i saw a new story on
gamespot on kojima on why he won't make
horror games anymore and i'm expecting
this really artistic in-depth creative
answer um
but no i get scared very easily is what
he said i hadn't read it but that was my
husband
uh he said i get scared easily he told
ign that's the practical reason for why
he doesn't want to uh act and then he
also said actually this is true of
alfred hitchcock as well as steven
spielberg because they scare easily
because i scariestly it's actually easy
for us to make something as scary
because we understand what is scary his
peers
his uh his contemporaries
because he competes with them alfred
hitchcock um if you don't know it
directed uh transformers
and steven spielberg was uh did eternal
sunshine of the spotless mind one of my
favorites you're thinking of e.t yes
um so there's that start off with an
easy one uh i also
saw oh
more comedy conan the dev behind conan
exiles explains its donk
i think that's what i wrote down
conan exiles explains why the game has
genital physics and an endowment slider
i wrote down dong physics in mind well
it's really just one set of genitalia
that has physics but it's not just
strong physics because you can enhance
and
decrease the size of the female
characters breasts as well and that was
the reasoning i think of genitalia i
think of me too well yeah because
breasts aren't genitalia but uh i
believe the quote was equality and all
that yes
which developer was it funcom
uh and i read ama recently that kotaku
picked up reported on it funcom expanded
the topic saying it was decided early on
that nudity would be a part of the game
because it fits with the lore and the
setting as for the endowment slider
which if you can't figure out those what
those words imply you can
slide your endowment
like how much money i had my bank
account yes
slider was a natural evolution of that
fun concept especially seeing we had a
similar similar slider for breasts
equality and all that it's just very
erudite
they know what sells joey uh one of our
gameplay producers here has a uh feature
up that essentially shows off these
features
his wing
not his but his character well his
avatar's weighing yes
cross that off the list true art
i got one before i get into something a
little more serious i have one that i'm
sure pete will like uh so uh this popped
up on neogaf the other day um
originally posted by esmith08734
a fairly young kid flew to new york city
to be the first person in the world to
obtain a nintendo switch on march 3rd i
don't really understand how he's going
to do this but he plans on waiting at
the store for a month i think he dropped
out of school to pursue being a youtuber
pretty insane he's doing this he post
daily vlogs i think etc uh yeah so
apparently he rented an airbnb nearby
because you can't just camp out in line
this early on okay so he is going to
lock down the first spot every day until
march 3rd okay when the switch releases
um pete was
i guess i don't think i was in the
office at the time but apparently pete
you just burst into a ramp the other day
it was kelly's beautiful it was
beautiful it was like 10 minutes and i
walked away to get water and i came back
and he was still talking about it it was
awesome i am horribly out of touch i'm
the first person to admit that like i
don't get what is popular these days if
being the first person to own a console
is the thing that you're gonna stake
like your future on by dropping out of
school yeah
man i don't know well you were also
saying that seems to be
a lot of what you don't like about the
perception of the video game industry
there's that too yeah i think
yeah i don't know i don't want to get
that too into it but yeah i think it's
really dumb i'm still only good at that
i think it's a stupid thing he's doing
it's not worth the time or any of the
energy that he's putting into it really
brief side note before the slider goes
past in our chat hector montamer said he
this is the first time he's tuning into
the lobby on the live stream and the
fire alarm went off at school
so uh hopefully everyone's all right
that's probably just his punishment for
watching the lobby during class true no
just kidding if you're in school don't
pay attention your teacher watch us
kelly you were saying about this i'm i'm
not gonna even touch that one oh uh it
was just it was really good because um
pete was so upset
about um
the dropping out of school part
which i think that's the part that
irritated me the most
because
don't i mean stay in school in all
seriousness don't drop out of school to
be a youtuber you have spare time you're
a student
i mean we just laughed about dong
physics
so i'm going to contradict myself here
but it's such a juvenile move to like
try to become
famous for being the first person to buy
a consumer product is that what we've
become as an as an audience as a you
know people who like video games a lot i
guess people like video games for
different reasons
some people like it because it makes
them popular yeah but uh i don't get it
i'll leave it at that uh
another one that popped up on kotaku as
well uh jason trier reporter over there
a writer editor was saying
they've been talking to uh gamestop
recently um like i think for his initial
story he talked to 20 employees um so
there's the thing called gamestop circle
of life
essentially
it sounds complicated but then the
implications of it become pretty obvious
so
if you're if you work at gamestop you're
kind of encouraged to push pre-owned
content when possible and they do this
by setting a quota
for pre-owned games and for any
pre-owned content that quota is a
percentage of total sales in dollar
amounts so while prescription like
subscript prescription cards you want to
get medicine at gamestop you need a
prescription card no for subscription
cards
you need to uh
that's a percentage that they need to
sell based on a total number of
transactions so any transaction they do
if they can get a percentage of those
that they give a subscription card to
the gamestop rewards program that's
that's easier but like i was saying the
pre-owned content quota is a percentage
of total sales so
what kotaku jason schreier discovered
was that a lot of employees were saying
from either their managers or just
because of this system they were feeling
forced and fearful for their jobs if
they didn't
push pre-owned content to the point that
sometimes people come into the store and
ask for like a new wii u
and they would have them in back but the
employee knowing that not only would
buying that wii u raised the
dollar amount that they had to hit a
percentage of with pre-owned they
wouldn't be selling a pre-owned they
would have to sell even more pre-owned
as the week or the month went by so they
would say no but we have a refurbished
one so that would raise the percentage
and keep the dollar amount down they
needed to meet so a lot of employees
saying they were either being encouraged
or feeling forced to lie to customers
saying
no we don't have new stuff you need to
buy our pre-owned that just came in the
other day yeah and it's hard for those
people to feel like they have a choice
honestly i've worked plenty of retail
jobs and you get these sort of things
from on high that you're told to do and
you can't and what are you gonna do you
can't argue with it yeah if you don't
meet those sales they'll let you go yeah
they did a follow-up saying uh i think
forbes like also talked to a few people
not as many as kotaku saying it might
have been a little bit exaggerated of
how fearful they were
but um
yeah so these that may be overblown was
the forbes headline uh reports of
gamestop is terrible circle of life
program may be overblown looking at it
here
um they were saying that it was just
kind of a case-by-case basis which i get
that some managers might be a little
more you know dictatorial in their
approach but that system itself does not
leave a lot of wiggle room in terms of
what you're trying to sell people if
you're i mean it's not a secret that
gamestop lives and dies by its pre-owned
content it's just a cycle that keeps
coming into the store you trade a new
trade in old games for new ones and then
those new ones come back in as used
games to be sold at a higher markup not
higher than 60 but higher than their
value uh and that's kind of shitty
especially if you are working gamestop i
don't think i've heard about good
practices at gamestop before so this
doesn't really be surprisingly
nice this doesn't surprise me but
uh it's still a shitty to hear
how that works and i'm sure
you know hopefully these reports will
make them
reconsider
and if it gets big i mean if forbes is
reporting on it then maybe it's who
knows
hopefully i mean i hope nobody gets uh
like there's no retaliation against
employees also like it doesn't continue
to negatively affect employees yeah and
then yeah eric green in the youtube chat
was asking if the company has the right
to fire their employees for not meeting
these quotas i think that was part of it
right that was like yeah
sure yeah they were like reserving the
right to actually do that if they didn't
meet this kind of it's not an arbitrary
quota because there are rules about it
but it is you're not doing what we asked
you to do yeah sorry bye
uh so yeah i will just keep
paying for stuff through amazon yeah
it's easy and
uh i don't think they have a practice
like that so hopefully they don't
all right that's the end of our news
reel so uh leave us your thoughts in the
chat i'll try to catch up while we get
into the new segments uh whether you're
on youtube or twitch again we have the
chat right here and we are welcoming you
to participate uh the neo review we are
getting to that stuff at the end of the
show tony on youtube so
fear not because i really like that game
i want to talk about it first off though
um the ghost ghost recon wildlands
closed beta was last week or open closed
for on or open beta what the [ __ ] is
going on
i'm sorry yeah well it's closed yes was
uh we were playing on ps4 and pc uh last
week in the office and over the weekend
i think it was like friday to sunday
we did a stream of it too and
uh if you don't know much about
wildlands yet it's essentially they're
making this open world sandbox in
colombia and you're essentially trying
to take down the drug cartel because
there aren't 300 movies and games where
you're doing that already it's fresh
it's absolutely trodden
never never been there um
but uh after the takeaway that like jake
decker was playing and he was the one
that kind of raised the idea for this
segment uh aaron samson was playing i
know rob tried it out i couldn't get
past the menu rob handler and jake
zacker while they were pressing the x
button yeah it said i was connected but
then there was this overlay saying you
can't connect to the servers but then in
the background on the main telescreen
said you're connected but then that
would go away and i would try to play a
game and said you're disconnected i
don't know what it was i i we've been
having problems with you like with for
on or ubisoft connections like something
with just within the office yeah it's
like that type or something like our nat
type which
no idea what cbs is up to but hopefully
they're not watching because i don't
want to be fired they're making that
show about the nerds i forget what it's
called
which one the show about the nerds the
show about the nurses
nice i actually didn't know what you're
talking about i don't know what cbs
sounds um you were kidding right
what you didn't forget the name of the
thing
after playing that people said you know
it's kind of a common phrase uh where as
new sequels come out and these
franchises start evolving and adapting
and kind of trying to figure out what
audiences want and what they're going to
pay for more specifically
it feels more like
people are saying this seems like
they're going for a gta thing with ghost
recons um i made the comparison watching
jake play you know like scoping out an
area kind of sneaking in i made the
comparison to metal gear solid five a
game which you and i both really like
kelly you were saying you haven't played
too much of it yet no okay it's
essentially just the the whole loop of
the stealth in an open world right and
you don't have to be stealthiness the
big thing they push i think it was an e3
reveal like two years ago um 2015 i
believe uh ubisoft is saying yeah you
can they showed the same gameplay
trailer twice just one day going in guns
blazing one being stealthy this looks
almost exactly like the first mission in
milk or soft
like the location of the first mission
totally yeah and it essentially
people are saying it doesn't feel like a
ghost recon game which
i
i don't name right i don't always like
like resident evil 7 doesn't feel like a
resident evil game but i think what it
does well sorry
at first glance it does not but then you
start playing and you see the roots of
it gotcha the people are saying they
don't see any tom clancy in this a lot
like aside from the aesthetic the
military aesthetic right that's not tom
clancy i thought you played as time
claims
that's uh
that's ding chavez the main character
from the old rogue rainbow six it's
nothing shot
have you seen the movies read the books
i used to be a huge tom clancy nerd
that's why i wanted to do this segment
um
and you were scripting that microphone
in anticipation of something i don't
know what i what no i'm not can we talk
about the name ding really quickly
it's ding chavez look up it's i'm not
kidding have you guys seen um clear and
present danger patriotic games all the
time
here's some ford stuff yes and then he
the one of the main recruits for rainbow
six is ding chavez
look it up you can play it uh i told
john louie to have he's like making fun
of it i told you
he has it ready i have to get like
rainbow six rogue spear footage ready
we're gonna get into the argument this
segment soon but i want to like show you
uh
what i like about stop that what i like
about um
like tom clancy stuff it's well okay
rogue spear is one of my favorite games
and i think that when you lose the
you can play this in third person too
which is what i always did it looks
cooler i wish that was ding chavos at
the bottom that's not that is uh
vladimir nabakov the author
isn't it he's spetsnaz now no um
it's
essentially wild lands like jake decker
were just chatting in the twitch chat uh
it feels like they're going for more of
a open world sandbox thing whereas like
you know the division was going for more
of the rpg lucry destiny kind of game
and
in some ways
and uh then you have rainbow six siege
which started off as this tactical team
shooter but now as they introduce the
updates aaron sampson plays it a lot
he's been saying it's becoming less and
less tactical and it's falling more into
that hero shooter
uh category almost which you know like
like overwatch battleborn class-based
shooter class-based shooter
terminology every time i hear the word
battleborn i get sad
i'll throw
battleborn into the conversation anytime
i think
that game's fun but
i wanted to talk to you guys about
whether you think tom clancy games are
losing their identity because i like i
said i i'm not always one of those
people who says like oh this doesn't
feel like a zelda game or this doesn't
feel like a metroid game but in this
case i don't want tom clancy to just
become this this homogeneous thing that
blends in with all the other franchises
because tom clancy games to me were
always that they were the tactical
things too and when they first showed
off the trailer for rainbow six patriots
when you had to make those decisions
like do i throw the civilian off the
bridge to let the bomb blow him up but
also not hurt like 500 more people like
that was cool because that was the you
know like the
fighting in the shadows when no one
really knows you're there kind of
there's no glory it's just these
preemptive military strikes uh rainbow
six vegas i love those two games they're
the tactical first person shooters but
so what does this retain that does
resemble tom clancy that's what that's
what everybody's saying with wildlands
it seems like there's even less tom
clancy than the division head
which the division didn't have much to
begin with just the aesthetic so it's
like tom clancy's just this i thought
that was a tom clancy yeah it's like two
actually
it's like a paint now
yeah
well i get i mean i can understand i
think that sometimes a franchise
deviating from its roots is can be a
good thing i
i also think like when you are a fan of
something that's known for like tom
clancy being known for tactical elements
um
having it shift
so far away from that when there are
other options for similar games that
are doing the same things it's trying to
do it's like okay well why did i bother
buying this game if i can play you know
black ops 3 and pick like a specialist
and it's basically like you have a sort
of hero
thing going on like why do i need
another game like this i went to tom
clancy for tactical stuff now i don't
have that so i can understand the
frustration
um yeah totally it's it's the wanting to
make money in the short term based on
these trends right and then but in the
long term what are you sacrificing maybe
it's what thomas wants
can i call him thomas sure
i think tom's i think it usually you
start with formal you start with the
formal thing and then when you get
familiar you call him tom yeah
clancy-son
okay
so
my boy t's games right now have been
kind of like losing what i love about
them and yeah short term they're kind of
maybe cashing in is really just being
reductive and being kind of mean to
ubisoft but i feel like they're cashing
in on the destiny loot grind um mmorpg
cooperative shooter experience
uh like i said rainbow six siege i think
is catering more to that class-based
shooter structure
um i think
there's a history here you don't know
about kelly
i'm scared and then eric green that
brings up a very good point in youtube
mike should ask himself if the marketing
of applying the tom clancy name works
and making him buy a game he may not
otherwise have bought very very good
point because
if the division was not a tom clancy
game i still would have tried it and i
think i would have had less exp uh
expectations whereas
i don't think i would care about
wildlands if it wasn't a tom clancy game
so there's a two it's a two-sided coin
right is it maybe more of the themes and
the setting that kind of makes you feel
like there's a stronger connection this
time around is something tom clancy
would be a part of but then the
mechanics fall short with uh wild lance
yeah probably yeah because that's the
original like uh tom clancy stuff was
about drug cartel uh in south america
and that's why i was attached to it but
like eric green mentioned i don't think
i would care about wildlands because it
looks like
it looks like they're going for a
dumbed-down vanilla kind of mellow sod 5
experience well we don't know if it's
done we don't we don't but well from
what we everybody's playing from what i
played it didn't feel like it but it
also was a beta it's a beta it doesn't
true uh yeah obviously this is all based
on my beta experience but
i didn't get like the last ghost recon
was future soldier and i actually really
liked that it wasn't the best one but i
think the campaign was really good i
think it emphasized this kind of
modern combat this like preemptive
military strikes with uh drones with
these like with robots and whatnot but
also it kind of
had some cool things to say about that
as it went through about
like
the dehumanization of war and whatnot
sure but
i still liked it because it felt like a
tom clancy game and like i said this is
weird for me because i usually
am not one of those people who says like
oh this doesn't feel like a zelda game
why are they doing this like they're
sacrificing made it great to begin with
in this case i feel like they're taking
they're picking apart one specific
franchise on ubisoft's part and just
kind of exploding it out to meet all
these different trends and that's why
i'm kind of worried because i i actually
played more than a division recently
it's been like six episodes of lobby
where i've said i wanted to get back
into playing and i did and i like the
survive mode i think that actually fits
into the division well for those who
don't know that's where you're actually
going through this uh post or like
disease infected post almost
post-apocalyptic manhattan
and try and survive through the cold and
through your thirst and hunger but
wildlands from what i've seen and from
what i've heard and from the brief time
i've played in the beta again it
did not feel like i was playing this
tactical game at all and that's what i
was looking for with it like a tactical
shooter in a sandbox i mean you're not
gonna be i don't think a game's gonna
come along anytime soon that's better
than metal gear solid five at doing that
yeah
and i don't
dislike the fact that they're going for
that but
it doesn't feel it feels like it's
missing the mark now the co-op the co-op
side of it makes it a little more
enticing i know jake decker and aaron
sampson were and rob handler were having
much more fun
playing
in co-op
and having a tutorial
in the middle of making yours here's how
to sit on a helicopter um
so i'll probably play this when it comes
out but like eric green had mentioned
would i be as interested if it wasn't
the tom clancy game no and i but i would
have been more interested in the
division i think if it was just its own
thing and i wasn't expecting it to be a
tom clancy game sorry correction i would
have enjoyed it more if i wasn't trying
if i didn't think it was a tom clancy
game so i
was just worried that in the long term
what does it even mean to be a tom
clancy game anymore like five years down
the road if all of these different
properties ghost recon i think
provision's brand new i think it's
already
doesn't it's been deluded and i wish
like rainbow six stuck to its roots so
people are in the chat are saying it's
still pretty tactical and i i agree but
i think um and aaron sampson has
has dissected the game a lot uh he's a
video producer here he was saying that
just like a lot of the updates they're
doing are making it more of just a
regular
shooter still tactical much more
tactical than you know like uh overwatch
or something of that ilk but now it's
just i feel like it's kind of being this
vanilla tactical shooter rather than
this really hardcore i hate using that
phrase because it sounds like i'm
alienating and marginalizing people that
just want these shooters but
i feel like tom clancy in the long run
and like you said maybe we're already
there and time clancy games don't mean
what they used to be
i'm sad now
don't feel bad for mike
but but then there's these rays of hope
like resident evil 7 i know i just
earlier used that example that was just
me thinking out loud because resident
six was the one where like what the [ __ ]
is this resident evil 7 is a return to
the roots which we keep saying but it
makes sense yeah i also definitely from
modern palettes and that's residual 7 i
have something else going up soon-ish
about why i think residual 7 is actually
really [ __ ] important game because
one of japan's biggest developers and
one of the most like leading franchises
at least well maybe not in recent years
but resident evil itself the fact that
they could kind of take a risk and go
back to survival horror
is kind of proof that maybe people
should do this so maybe you know like
obviously this is a stretch but maybe
ubisoft needs to look at resident evil 7
and say how can we
take what made tom clancy games great to
begin with and adapt it in our own way
rather than
follow destiny or follow
or how can we teach tom clancy name and
break out the things that people like
and make them their own franchise
exactly make another new ip
like the division but in its own kind of
game not a destiny
clone
yeah survival mode i guess if you're
gonna play division play survival mode
um
yeah the next splinter cell game will be
yeah if so blacklist speaking of
speaking of that splinter cell blacklist
thank you billy comb for bringing up
splinter cell i'm sure other people did
i just didn't see the chat um splinter
cell blacklist i really actually thought
did this well but that was what 2012
blacklist you guys remember someone in
the chat can you tell me what your
splinter cell blacklist was i'm
forgetting right now it was like at
least four years ago
i think they did a great job because you
have those three trees you can go down
where you actually you can play the
traditional splinter that way it was a
very good stealth game if you want to
but then they had these side quests when
you're going in
this mission is very much
stealth don't even get seen if you're if
these missions you will
immediately
fail if you're seen yeah kind of like a
dishonored like completely non-lethal
run or anything um and then there's this
one tree where it's assault and it felt
good for a third-person shooter it
didn't feel like splinter cell but it
was still an option um and then like the
last boss fight in that game is [ __ ]
i love everything about this game except
for that last boss fight blacklist i
think is an example of what tom clancy
games need to be it it took what made
splinter cell great to begin with and it
didn't sacrifice that but it also added
on to it and i think adapted it from
modern palettes and i really liked it
yep i don't know did you guys did you
play blacklist no but i mean just from
you describing it i think that's a
really smart
way to adapt
something for both like returning and
like returning players and introducing
it to new people is like giving options
i think that's smart it's hard to
execute sometimes but sure and then they
have like you kind of just saw like um
you mentioned black ops two and three or
sorry black ops yeah
black ops three with the specialists
yeah black ops also has that hub in the
campaign no black ops has that hub in
the campaign that's what call of duty
games started doing uh because infinite
warfare had it as well where you that's
where all the rpg mechanics are tied
into where you like upgrade your weapons
blacklist did that really well and i
think that was a very modern trope at
the time and it still is i guess but you
go back between missions to pick you
know that old school map which neo
actually has like a mario map you're
picking i'm comparing splinter saw to
mario you're picking like which parts of
the mushroom kingdom you want to
infiltrate
but anyway mario odyssey come in when
it's all blacklisted i haven't played it
i recommend it
um okay
i think we've talked enough about how
worried i am about time
i think so did you get that youtube kid
out of your system
yeah last week kelly what do you want to
vent about i secretly still hate it um i
uh
come back to me on that i'm angry about
so much
so much anger
all right uh for those just joining we
are going to get into neo and nintendo
switch
so we will get to those we have one more
segment we have a bit of an odd segment
for lobby stuff but i'm excited to show
it um
first off if you have any thoughts i see
um mr rashinator siege is still
extremely taxable the more operators
they have the more tactical it becomes i
totally agree i think they're still
going for the hero class-based shooter
but
um i appreciate the fact that it's still
much more tactical than like overwatch
or
uh battleborn or what other class-based
shooters came out last year you're
trying so hard not to say hero shooter i
love it yeah
but also when i oh titanfall 2 had like
class-based shooter things like with the
titans they went more to that
no hero shooter because titan used to be
a class-based shooter and then they made
it into a hero shooter with these
superhuman these super-powered titans
one has like flame powers what are their
perks like mike what kind of work when i
described let me describe this like
someone an entity that shoots flames
sure mainly has powers around flames or
powers around lasers or powers around
missiles what would you call those like
someone with superpowers that you know
does good deeds
what would you call that peter brown now
see i would look and try to figure out
the roles that they fill in a general
sense then apply that to a class i
wouldn't get hung up on superficial
details like fire okay people in the
chat
let me know your thoughts about tom
clancy i'll try to keep up but also
tweet at me mike mccarty peter brown
callie plaggy for your thoughts yes next
segment i'm going to intro a little bit
weird so people who watch the lobby
often or just are at game spot in
general often we'll know rob hanlery um
but also you probably noticed you know
in the past year or so year two years
we've been uh branching into
entertainment movies tv things that
cross over with the games audience
because you know as people here and
anime
kelly's leading that charge now um as
people who enjoy video games here we
also you know that's not all we do in
our free time that's not all we like to
cover at work we cover uh movies tv
anime and um
uh buddy over here he's uh in charge of
our gamespot universe team which
essentially that is what gamespot
universe is for those of you who don't
know i realize this is redundant for
people who've been seeing it a lot um we
even cover wrestling but we did
something recently with a
feature where people went on and talked
about
the movies their favorite movies that
are so bad that they're good because of
it and i figured robs would be a good
one to show because you're all probably
familiar with rob and i'm gonna have
john luke roll that right now and then
we're gonna let that go into our next
segment
mine will have to go to leprechaun 4 in
space why here's one scene that will
paint a nice little picture after the
space marines blow up the leprechaun
with a grenade one of the space marines
takes a piss on the leprechaun's leg the
leprechaun then through magic travels up
the urine stream and into the
guys dingus later on in a hot and steamy
scene with another with another space
marine the leprechaun uh
bursts through the man's
penis
and says let that be a lesson to your
lab always wear a prophylactic
watch it
rob hanley thank you uh
that is one segment from a longer
feature that you can go watch i will be
up soon if it's not up now uh pete
brown's in it too what movies you talk
about mine's not very good but i talked
about uh cool dead alive way to sell it
i just had low self-esteem yeah
uh did it live have you ever seen it no
no no but i'll go watch the feature and
see why i should see it
go check it out at gamespot.com it
should be up
soon if not now like i said um and yeah
like keep up to date on we have a lot of
good content with like uh you know
covering movies kelly's doing a lot of
anime stuff uh like i said i'm trying to
do an anime thing yes like 35th
anniversary of akira and i'm trying to
make some cool [ __ ] happen okay i'm like
this close to starting the conversation
yeah you're a tattoo from a cure don't
you i do nice i i'm working on a romance
anime feature for valentine's day if
you're into that sort of thing it was a
lot of fun
uh anime bass or video games anime okay
yeah romance anime who would you want to
romance from anime right
no
well anyway the
segment i want to talk about is can
games be
so bad that they're good i think there
are a few obvious standouts that we want
to talk about but i
thought that was that games universe
thing which we wanted to show off was a
good segue into this the first one i
want to get into the one that i want
that i want to bring to the table is
obviously deadly premonition because
sure clearly they were going for it uh
but in what regard though b-movie
detective cheesy dialogue kind of like
i'm with you on all of that and with you
and all of that but where i see it
incidentally bad is the fact that like
the animations are really cool mechanics
aren't that great they're not many
mechanics speak of but they're not great
right to begin with playing the game is
not that good watching it is fascinating
as hell did you play through the whole
thing no i couldn't bring myself to
finish it yes yeah it's you really have
to be ready for it it is
storm prince on youtube that deadly
premonition is so good that it's good
uh
it is
yeah tough to get through not in the
same way obviously a movie you can watch
and it's awful and it's funny because
it's awful and you're like cool it's
only 90 minutes i'll be done 90 minutes
i can sit back like maybe drink while
i'm doing this i can eat i could do any
number of things with your body
like holding a cup and drinking or
something i don't know i went way too
into that like a game the game you have
agents you're involved in the shittiness
so it's tough it's tough that's why i
wanted to the segment was can games be
so bad that yeah because you have to put
a lot of time into a game yeah to get
anything out of it in a lot of cases not
in all cases obviously but like a movie
you can watch for an hour and then
you're like ah i watched the room and it
was i was drunk and it was so funny i
think as humans we have the right to
subject ourselves to
a waste of time every once in a while
uh whether it be a 90 minute movie or
however long deadly premonition is but
like you said callie games take a lot
longer they involve more agency you
can't just
ugh i forgot how bad some this game is
but the dialogue is really bad it's
i i encourage you to try it um
the director's cut i think is the way to
go i think it
made a few of the bad parts not as bad
to get you through i mean look at this
oh man animations it looks like this
that's the sirloin steak is somehow
shrinking in that toilet
um this theater that's way too tall
uh
i don't know what's going on i forgot
that's a direct reference to twin peaks
but yeah yeah and that's a lot of this
twin peaks yeah deadly premonitions twin
views i've never seen twin peaks sorry
oh yeah it's a tough show to get through
it's very much a soap opera for like 75
percent of the show is it so bad that
it's good
in in time yes okay at points it is i
think a lot of people say that about
what the second season yeah yeah the
draft people are like bringing up the
whistle uh goob and bob jones what is
that what's the whistle theme is that
the the
like main theme of the game
i can't we don't have volume on our tv
so yes they said yes okay super saiyan
moses says yes no i think he was
answering is this a bethesda game which
it's not
uh who did the deadly premonition uh uh
it was uh sweary yes sorry he did that
as well as what else did he do oh he did
d4
um dark dreams don't die right he's done
is that really a bunch of stuff no no
he's done more than that no no if dark
dreams don't die what the acronym stands
for yeah i think so oh
did you just guess i didn't guess it was
somewhere in my subconscious but i guess
that's where it was i found it
proud of you any other examples you guys
want to talk about there are a few pete
you probably want to talk about yakuza
yeah it's weird though because it's
okay it's like the combat is bad
movement feels bad the graphics are bad
but it's not a game that's like good
because it's bad but it's a game that i
will tolerate its poor qualities because
the stuff outside of the shitty stuff is
great what about really good like is
zero good so you said yakuza did you
mean this
oh the most recent one okay yeah because
yeah i was we watched the stream that
pete and rob did the oh
that one line from the underwear guy
what's his name walking erection
yeah i really just wanted you to see he
got hold of conan's dong slider
you wish
what are some other uh here we have a
footage of yakuza zero up right now yeah
what else is bad about this game you
just want me to talk about why this game
sucks
you gave it an eight right you really
liked it and i i've it's been getting
like positive reception across the board
if you're really into it gravy biscuits
is right this game is awesome the
problems
are obvious though i mean you can't deny
that this game is deficient in so many
ways
but uh the rest of it's great
i don't know how you could give it less
than an eight with a character like
walking erection
um yeah someone had mentioned i figured
forgive me your name pass me buying the
twitch chat bring it back up if you can
uh the game informer our friends over
there they do replay yeah and um the
facebook like community group for replay
is called the overblood community group
and that's because like overblood was
the first time they did a super replay
which is when they played through an
entire game where uh they died like
right at the beginning and over blood is
one of those things where it's really
cheesy there's a robot i forget its name
but there's all these inside jokes with
the replay community because of over
blood and they call it like the super
over blood
replay um hopefully people in the chat
if you're any game informer fans bring
that up but over blood is definitely
i've never played it and i only watched
a little bit of it because i didn't have
the time to go through the whole thing
with the game of former crew but
uh apparently it's a seminal part in the
replay canon i'm waiting for footage
here we got footage of this game it's
yeah forgive me i think we might have it
but it's just polygonal really shitty
graphics here we go this is the
beginning you have to find this vest
that keeps you warm so you don't die
and that's how i push blocks yeah
and uh it doesn't i forget the robot's
name but it becomes this this idiotic
robot that just pops up at the worst
times is it turd
but the beginning is the most obtuse
puzzle that just doesn't make sense when
you're trying to get out of this frozen
lab
voice daniel
dan reichert from giant bomb talking
right now that i'm kind of talking over
i don't know if i'm talking over him or
not
honestly
but in a robot i encourage you to go
watch that it was like a few years ago
like dan riker's still a game former
before he went to giant bomb but uh it's
worth watching it's funny
um someone mentions god hand here very
similar i think it's archangel uh l
three three seven one very similar to
yakuza in so many ways like
it doesn't play very well it doesn't
look that good
but actually castlevania 64 is really
similar no i don't know but it's the
humor it's the sort of just oddball
nature of it all that makes it palatable
okay um i saw somebody mention i'm sorry
i did not catch your name uh blinks
that xbox game did you ever play that
game the cat the time traveling cats
okay so i don't think i ever finished it
i i don't know if this game is actually
bad or if i just remember it that way uh
because i it's the it's an original xbox
game but basically you just like
stop time and do stuff but you're like
an anthropomorphic
cat um and that's the shittiest
description i can give
it's an awesome name
my horse prince oh oh my god i really
wanted to talk about my horse prince as
well so yeah so a lot of dating sims are
are super bad um and my horse prince is
a mobile game where you date a boy like
an anime boy who has a horse body and um
it's very entertaining and ridiculous
but not a good game by any means but
it's one of those i i hesitate to say
like something that you play when you're
drunk but um it's one of those things
where you're like you can just giggle
about it all night it sounds like the
next netflix original
my horse bojack horseman is the head of
aurora's body of will our net in
animation form yeah so this is he's a
reverse bojack horseman what if they
just splice them then just be a show
about a horse
or a man yes that's not nearly as cool
oh here's footage i see what you're
saying now ooh a good looking horseman
at that oh yeah look at him he's sparkly
there's nothing normal about you
why is she smiling when she says this oh
yeah can we talk about the voice acting
yes so there's just smiling a lot
you're more scary than strange this is a
terrifying experience so sweet direct tv
wow that's porsche i don't know about
shut up i don't know about you but uh
that's the kind of date i want is uh
terrifying
oh my god does he like yes we'll take
reservations for three one for his butt
does he ever blink
um she's blinked a few times she's
blinking he's i don't think he blinks
see the fact that he has horse ears it
leads me to believe that
he's an imposter it's just a face on a
horse not a head a human head it's a
human head on a heart i also so gravy
biscuits on twitch says how full
boyfriend i would like to refute that
huddle hot off a boyfriend is a
fantastic dating sim is that the pigeon
one yes yeah it's a deconstruction yeah
of the dating sim genre and if you've
played every route like i did
because i don't have a life then you
would know that it's fantastic but it
has bad quality i mean the little
sensation is is spotty at times but the
reliance on puns is pretty shitty yeah
yes but i wouldn't say that's what like
that's not why i play it that's another
question is like what is so bad it's
good is it like with movies that are so
bad they're good it's like oh this is
they tried really hard to make a good
movie they did not make a good they
thought they succeeded yeah how funny
the room is like the quintessential
example of that whereas with a game it's
more like oh
we're kind of talking about stuff that's
like either goofy or that we like
despite its bad qualities so i guess
it's a different qualifier cause that's
really the question of the segment is
like can games be so bad they're good i
think it's a very different kind than
with movies or shows back to the room
real quick tommy we sew his retconned
himself i saw him in texas at a
screening of the movie and he was
basically like oh yeah i'm just very
much into dark comedy this is a comedy
like he's claiming that this is all he
did not
himself
didn't people think he was that
um
robber the plane
hijacker from the 50s who stole a bunch
of money and disappeared oh i know who
you're talking about people thought don
draper was going to be this guy as well
at the end of mad men i won't say
whether or not he is because if you
haven't finished mad men you should well
it shows
fight fight fight um
oh my god you turned bright red so yeah
so you brought up a good point deadly
premonition is bad so bad it's good
because of its like cinematic or lack
thereof qualities right but
something like goat simulator is
actually bad because of its mechanics
but it makes it fun but i think that's a
better example of how a game can be bad
but good beast is all gang beasts too
yeah like
i don't want to do it i don't want a gif
made of me wait john luke do you have
the gif of pete ready no we'll show goat
simulator first um i mean that that
definitely is the difference between
like a so bad it's good uh
movie in a so bad it's a good game is
like because games have
game play and mechanics like that can be
the main
problem
oh yeah
yeah eric green again also said it you'd
probably have to expect it to have bad
qualities to be able to enjoy it like if
it was bad out of nowhere you'd have a
much harder time uh every single person
in the chat
is saying that mad men is really good
yeah
um okay taste maker extraordinaire yeah
i think gang beast was another good uh
example of how a game could be bad but
it's good just because they purposely
made the mechanics not that
uh tight right so you're just gonna say
that almost maybe
no i feel like they really tried to make
that i mean like i mean that's polishing
oh like surgeon simulator
and they're struggling to find b-roll i
think
uh if they can find surgeon simulator
footage before we end this segment
that'd be sweet
people talking about earth defense force
earth defense force yeah especially as
it went on it became
real what is happening i don't know if
the production crew knows this but we're
hearing all the audio from the b-roll
you're screening nicholas smith and
youtube mad men's not overrated i don't
believe you yeah nikki smith
okay anyway
nicholas smith uh
i'm gonna end this segment so we can get
on to nintendo switch which a lot of
people are asking for and then we're
gonna talk about neo after that um i'm
gonna switch over to the next segment um
we're gonna switch things up
um
anyway let us know any other games that
you think are so bad
they're good
what is this audio in our studio right
now
i am brad is a good one too all right
i'm moving on uh let us know on twitter
mike marty kelly plaggy peter brown hit
us up with games you think are so bad
they're good next segment we're finally
talking about the nintendo switch
more specifically will the nintendo
switch help or hurt the 3ds
this is based on a
story that ran or like an interview that
nintendo high ups did uh which kind of
contradicted the stuff they originally
said about 3ds and the switch i have the
story up first off i want to get you
guys thoughts we kind of touched on this
back when we talked about the switch
around its announcement but kelly do you
think the switch
will help or hurt or would what effect
will have on 3ds
so um the best example i can come up
with that would support like
helping the 3ds is pokemon go
supposedly bolstered sales of sun and
moon so it didn't compete directly with
sun and moon because they were separate
experiences on separate platforms that
were made tailor-made for each of those
platforms and so i think
um
like uh i did i reviewed poochie and
yoshi's woolly world which is a port of
the wii u version and i think that it
works better on
uh 3ds for example so i think certain
things work better better on a
completely mobile platform um like the
3ds versus the switch which is uh
something that peter brought up which is
it's a console that can be mobile it's
not intended to be
like a traveling handheld um and so i
think
for the
user base that's already like really in
love with their 3ds like i carry my 3ds
with me everywhere the selling point for
the switch is like oh you can kind of
play it up close
if you feel like it but that's not
really how it's intended to play to be
played in all the games that are made
for it are
console games first and foremost and so
i don't think they'll necessarily
compete with each other i think the
challenges in marketing and nintendo's
had that problem before with marketing
where with the wii u they struggled a
lot to properly differentiate that from
the wii for kind of the i don't i really
hate using like casual but the more like
lay person or like you know your grandma
who knows what a wee is nintendo called
like the family audience right yeah so
they really struggle to differentiate
the wii u and so i think that's the
biggest challenge is how do they market
it so you know that this isn't actually
a handheld it's something that can be
played on the go
but it's not a replacement for a 3ds
they're definitely tackling i think the
problem of audience and perception
really well because all of their
marketing for switch has shown adults
yes you have not seen any
you might be right
but the point is 3ds is geared towards
kids right i mean i think that is a
pretty big differentiator and the switch
looks like a very sort of like high-end
device especially in person like super
impressed with the build quality on that
thing a 3ds is something you can just
toss around like it's made to sort of be
durable it's not really like a refined
piece of equipment so the marketing i
think they might be doing a better job
this time because they are getting
around some of that confusion um
but yeah like
i think you pretty much covered most of
the points you know that really need to
be said i mean they're different
products with different aims so you got
hands-on with the switch in new york uh
about a month ago right i touched it at
the reveal
north american review at least and
you were saying this is not
anywhere near the like you were saying
the portability of the 3ds this isn't
something you're going to see on the bus
a lot right it's i mean you might see it
but it's certainly not
like
i don't know about you guys when i play
stuff like on a plane or whatever i
kind of just like keep it to myself i
don't
have the world understand that i'm
playing a freaking video game and i'm
you know having a good time
the switch is not huge right i mean it
is
the screen is the same size as the
gamepad of the wii u and the bezel
around it is not that much bigger right
so it's not huge but it's also not small
and compact and i think you know again
because the experiences that are gonna
be made for to more console like games
to play a thing for 15 20 minutes on
your commute
even 45 minutes you're not gonna get as
much out of it as if you're really
settling in to play something else
whereas so many 3ds games are like
here's a 15-minute mission that you can
get done and accomplished absolutely
close it up move it you know move along
yeah like the dungeons and like link
between worlds right there's a lot of
dungeons in that game but they're
they're almost bite-sized same like yeah
i mean
as opposed to twilight princess the
dungeons could take you like 45 minutes
um yeah whereas like what like i didn't
like animal crossing city folk very much
because that was on wii and it just
didn't make sense to drop into my town
for 15 minutes it makes so much more
sense on on handheld so it's just like
totally different platforms it
yeah yeah yeah it seems like this in
this case my ideal situation with the
switch would be what it seems like
they're going for i'm playing breath of
the wild and then
i don't know like they just showed a
laundromat or something i have to get up
and go semi-close by or something or to
like a cafe across the street to get
coffee or to go to the bookstore because
i'm
pretty intellectual i don't know if you
guys know this
i'm not just kidding i didn't think that
you knew how to read but i'm working on
it if i screw up your chat comments
that's because you can't read um but
then the comments here um
someone there did an interview with uh
shinya takahashi the gm of nintendo's
entertainment planning and development
division and yoshiaki koizumi edi the
nintendo enchantment planning and
development deputy gm
they discussed the possibility of an
upgraded model of switch potential
accessories and more and then we could
also talk about that like how they might
update joy cons outside of just
aesthetics um like
there was those there was that concept
like a month ago or something that
showed what else could be attached i
mean think about any little like in-game
graphic or like little meter or you know
device
if it's a reasonable size you can
interact with that and put it on a
controller like i think you were talking
about the yokai spinning wheel thing
yeah yeah like so simple you just you
just sell that you bundle it with the
game players put that on and they're
good to go and that creates a really
interesting proposition because that
means man the switch can transform to be
so many things to so many different
people
in terms of power upgrades that's a
no-brainer i mean that this is not like
a weird crazy console it's like a tablet
tablets get upgraded all the time nvidia
is definitely working on tech that will
surpass what is in switch the switch
stuff is outdated so uh i would not be
surprised if in 18 months or two years
we saw some sort of announcement like
you know this might be completely
off-base this comparison but it sounded
more like the way they were describing
how uh these two executives were saying
how they want to update the switch
sounded more like an android like you
can take
take it apart almost and put new joy
cons on it or new accessories modular
yeah
yeah but they've also as opposed to like
the ps4 pro the xbox scorpio which is
more of like an updated iphone well in
the past though they've talked about
creating tools for developers that allow
them to port between devices really
easily so to to me that would say
porting to
things that are maybe more powerful or
you know coming down the road okay um
but yes i think you're correct in your
assumption as well that you can really
tailor this thing with a lot of
interesting attachments yeah
um but yeah so and then this interview
was with time and then on gamespot we
were talking about how also of note
where koizumi's comments on where switch
stands in relation to 3ds which is the
segment we were talking about
he didn't bring up the 3ds but he did
lay out a scenario which seemingly
leaves a little room for it um
unless you're going the route that we're
talking about we're hoping the nintendo
switch will be a system that will be the
constant in your gaming life koizumi
said whereas previously you would play
certain things in your home system and
certain things on your handheld our hope
is that nintendo switch can be the
system that bridges both of those and
becomes the constant system that you're
always using that's interesting
especially because they said that
there's not going to be any street pass
which is something that people love
about 3ds sure that's that's the reason
i carried mine around with me yeah yeah
same i always have it on in my backpack
so switch sounds like it's going to be
if based on that quote it sounds like
you know oh sorry there's more but my
hope is that with nintendo switch being
a system that you can play at home and
bring with you you're going to be able
to find more of those moments when we're
able to play the games that we all enjoy
and be able to play them that much more
i mean they're not gonna they're not
gonna back away from the promise you
know in an interview about this thing
being portable right i mean they're
gonna try to sell it from every angle
they can
um
but yeah i'd be surprised if the 3ds was
phased out because i hope not 3ds is one
of my favorite things i own i can see
the ds line being upgraded yeah you know
i mean soonish yeah i think it's i think
it probably needs to i mean
especially compared to vita it's
outdated but once you have the switch
next to it you know the resolution on
these screens the sort of graphics
you're looking at it's gonna
be i think underwhelming for a lot of
people
um we give nintendo [ __ ] all the time
for their library not being the best in
recent years you look at the 3ds it's
unreal yeah that's like one of my
favorite libraries there is it includes
the ds library because those names are
compatible yeah and then you have like
classics on the for like virtual or
sorry eshop and whatnot um
but yeah it doesn't it's just weird that
those quotes kind of sounded
contradictory to what they originally
laid out yeah i mean bridging bridging
the gap
is probably the interesting part of that
quote for me because um like there were
you know all those rumors about pokemon
stars being like oh the third version of
sun and moon
coming to switch and like there were
graphical things in sun and moon that i
thought like oh this looks extra weird
on 3ds like it belongs
on something a little bit like a step up
and so i don't know if that means a
replacement or like
extra features that if you play
something on your 3ds and then you have
you know this add-on on your switch or
whatever like i don't know what bridging
the gap means that's that's like the
question the big question mark for me on
whether or not that'll help or hurt the
3ds it's what they mean by that they'll
probably lean
more into mobile in terms of bridging
the gap between hardware
yeah honestly because that i mean that's
what they're using for
some matchmaking some lobby stuff
yeah because they we still don't know
a ton about we actually like kotaku put
up a pretty good article basically
saying like yeah we're a month away from
switch and we should really know a lot
more i mean it it really stands to
question will there be online day one
i don't know have we seen the ui yet
barely yeah barely you didn't see any of
that oh right no they had debug ui at
the event that i was at but right you
didn't see you're
sorry you were playing games but you
didn't see like a home menu or anything
right okay whenever they went to that
they were hiding it and they were doing
something secret i'm serious oh
seriously seriously they had individual
safes next to each stage well there was
a nintendo of some other country had put
out a commercial and they forgot to
green screen and gameplay footage over
the tablet and we actually got a look at
the debug so i did see what it looked
like eventually uh but then since
nintendo has shown like a screenshot or
two what it actually looks like in
trailers where they did cover up the
green screen footage you probably just
said something uh pretty insightful and
helpful but all i was imagining was
these thumbprint activated safes next to
each station and you just sneaking
around knocking out nintendo employees
and scanning their like eyeballs
not knowing that they're thumbprint
scanners
and then you actually didn't what's
going on in there
and what in your head i don't know
i just like to imagine you thinking
you're solid snake and knocking out
people and trying to scan their eyeballs
on the thumbprint thing and then like
you do this with the thumbprint like oh
that's all i need to do
um
what it wouldn't be a good segment
uh
we didn't talk about knocking people out
go off the rails the last second we're
about to pull into the station and nope
um
yeah because that's how you drive a
train that's got a wheel and everything
we ran out of coal uh one of those
dastardly villains had tied someone to
the tracks and threw it off snidely
whiplash yes
who snidely whiplash a did you make it
up in b if you didn't what's that from i
wish i'd made it up it's from rocky
bowling call oh you young boy is that
the moose and the cow
one of them's a moose right rocky's nick
moose
rocky's a squirrel
i would have made that same mistake yeah
he's a flying squirrel to be specific
what those things like sugar gliders
that's the same thing as a flying
squirrel those things are so no i want
one of my house
you want to own one i really want a
raccoon i want a pet raccoon uh i saw
one on my run the other day and he
looked very confused at what cars were
and i did not want to go near him
because i've heard they can be vicious
but i'm basing that entirely off the
movie elf
when i say i've heard vicious i'm just
thinking of what he says does someone
need a hug and then gets hugged with
claws yep
okay uh let us know what you think are
you worried at all about the switch
impact on the 3ds are you hoping like
cali said that it would just supplement
it are you in general looking for more
info about the switch like we are a
month before release almost exactly a
month a little few shorter than five
days and we will know more about the
console in the coming weeks hopefully
we'll get some in the office and we'll
be able to tell you more but in the
meantime yeah tweet at me mike mccarty
kelly plaggy peter brown uh keep hitting
us up in the chat i'll do my best to
keep up there's a bunch of people
chatting right now but
yeah thank you yeah
all right now we're on to the new
release of the day
miguel concepcion uh is
pretty close to being done with this
review for neo yes it is
production yes yeah we haven't published
it yet uh we all played it in like
varying
very expensive time
yes i played it for 30 minutes yeah i
played it for a few hours and
i really like this game so far and i was
not expecting to because
it was actually kind of an eye opener um
this sounds like a weird tangent i know
i do those a lot but this actually has
merit um in like a month
in about a month is uh
did i just unplug this can you still
hear me uh in about a month is the
castlevania symphony tonight 20th
anniversary um
97 it released that would make it i'm
doing some math right now um and i
forget what day it is in march but
uh i was looking at neo and it reminded
me of symphony tonight because
neo is clearly going for dark souls they
have in previews they've told us that's
what they're doing uh it's team ninja
who's famous for ninja gaiden he's
taking ninja gaiden and applying some of
the mechanics there and some of the
minor things to a dark souls structure
in that
very hard um
you know fighting mechanics uh you know
you're gathering this experience that
you can lose when you die death is a
huge deal but it's also kind of the norm
uh it's necessary well i guess not
necessarily if you want to go through
the game without dying but that'd be
very hard um these kind of like
interlacing worlds that
are you know very complicated and
whatnot and uh there are a lot of
similarities we're going to go into it
more we're going to talk more about how
neocompares the bloodborne but i was
wondering i was like this is really fun
but like what are the kind of
questions that get raised when you're
going to rip ripoff is a strong word but
essentially
take that take a game and almost clone
it but then i was looking at symphony
the night and they essentially you know
castlevania games were kind of
riding off of metroid's steam right a
little bit but you could also
say that about
magic
metroid was kind of
well zelda metroid came out not too far
apart yeah but even zelda is very
similar it's just a different different
perspective and you know the saying goes
like game design is all just iteration
so i was thinking like what other
i'd like to see maybe more franchises
kind of take what makes their
ips um
special like ninja gaiden with the uh
the very well designed combat and those
games were difficult in their own right
i'm gonna apply that to something with
the structure of a dark souls or a
bloodborne like i don't know maybe like
you could figure out a way maybe
maybe you could take a tom clancy game
and make it like dark souls
maybe the next splinter cell will be
like dark souls for those people who are
just joining that joke won't make sense
at all but uh
that would be cool
a shooter with like dark souls structure
i think we talked before the show about
the movie
equilibrium oh equilibrium that's that's
how you pronounce it you pronounce the
french way equilibrium uh
the gunkata
no what gunkata yeah yeah the grandson
clerics christian bale tay diggs who's
from syracuse okay uh no rochester some
upstate new york city i only bring this
up to hear him ramble oh that's what
happened earlier it's i was there for
that
equilibrium it's like a movie about a
society where like people aren't allowed
to have feelings and there are enforcers
and christian bale plays one of these
people and he stops taking his
medication so he starts having feelings
tell us like fahrenheit 451 art's not
allowed sure i think not having a
feeling sounds cool i like that yeah
they yeah they take a medication for it
and so that's cool they train these
officers in the art of gunfighting uh
where you learn a position for every
possible scenario that could ever happen
so you could literally walk into a room
and follow this kata so you do these
moves and no matter what everyone in the
room is gonna die and you'll be okay the
famous i think the one that comes to
mind is there's a bunch of these people
holding out defending these paintings
uh hold on i forget what they're called
they go to the narrows or whatever they
might be batman i'm just getting my
christian battle stuff mixed up but he
kicks down this door uh the gramaton
cleric he kicks down the door slides in
on the door everybody starts shooting
the lights go out and then all of a
sudden in the brief light flies from his
gun you hear this like whooshing sound
as he sweets like
and i'm not exaggerating these movements
he goes behind his head he goes like
under each arm
sorry uh and
yeah he's got these like double desert
eagles that he's using
what does that have to do with dark
souls you were talking why are we
talking about
you're talking about applying dark souls
like combat with a game that is based on
guns sure yeah yeah
weapon stances gunkata standards i mean
christian bale you could also just do
realistic like death if you're shot or
sure you know yeah something like that
totally
um
but we also wanted to talk about how neo
compares to bloodborne how it's better i
just forget that previous segment
um
just i feel like there's more depth here
um we did so neo uh eric tay who is
close to finishing the game he might
finish that i think uh he came in saying
it's a little more like bloodborne than
dark souls very much like dark souls
structurally it feels a little more like
bloodburn bloodborne i think it's uh
faster paced dark souls 3 kind of took a
little bit from bloodborne and how
you're sorry can be dodge oriented if
you wanted to but watching neo footage
here um it looks like a ninja gaiden
game in terms of mechanics um but you
know it's very difficult but it's like
this open world rpg and open world is
kind of uh
disingenuous i'll get to that soon but
it's also very story oriented much more
it's not this oh like kind of
translucent story that bloodborne told
yeah that's what i was going to bring up
is um like in miguel's uh review and
progress he talked a lot about the um
[Music]
character not like specific the main
character but like the the
charm isn't the right word either but
like the the the
style of the game it sets it apart from
bloodborne and dark souls in that it it
has its own unique flair um
inside japanese folklore yeah and i
that's the part that appeals to me the
most is like the the historical aspect
there's a lot of historical figures
uh in neo um and so that sets the part i
know that's kind of not what you were
going for because we're talking about
mechanics and no no feel but written
down yeah yeah that's that's the big
thing that stood out to me because
that's kind of that's usually what i
focus on in games i'm super drawn to the
historical japanese setting um yeah this
is based on your character is pretty
based on um
william adams he was the first like
western he showed up in japan in like
the 16th century and he was the first uh
second western person to be a saint yeah
let's do it and then he trained
like christian val did an equilibrium um
this was like what seven 17th century
16th i believe 15 80 something okay if
memory serves
maybe that would be 16th century right
yes okay i get that mixed up all the
time um but
other ways it's kind of similar to dark
souls in bloodborne uh weapon stances
dark souls 3 had the weapon arts
bloodborne has the trick weapons that
can switch between like
you know the hammer the ker camera or
the sword that it plunges into the sword
stone um
each weapon in neo has three stances
high low and mid and you can see here if
you're watching the gameplay down to
bottom right it shows you uh the one on
the right is just your sword of sheath
but other than that is high low and mid
high is more based on damage and
attacking mid is kind of a defensive and
then low low damage but it makes it
easier to dodge you're not wasting as
much key which is the stamina ki which
is a huge deal in this game even more so
than the stamina in dark souls or
bloodborne
it
you first of all you can see on the
enemies you could see their stamina
underneath their health bar which is big
because if their stamina runs out and if
your stamina runs out either or you like
freeze it is much more of a penalty than
in dark souls it's much more punishing
you kind of have to recover quickly
but same with enemies if they do it
obviously bosses and mini bosses will
have much more key but these enemies if
they run out you can go up and do these
uh like finishing attacks um and then
you also you know can kind of manage
yours by doing these key pulses uh if
you see the stamina bar here in the
gameplay when it drains there's this
blue segment really quick oh [ __ ] we
just use the
the guardian spirit attack which i'll
get into but you have this brief second
to refill the key you just used uh if
you press r1 like right after you attack
at the right time
which miguel concepcion who played
through this game said he i don't think
he used it much or he was just saying
you don't have to use it and you don't
you can get through the game without it
you can just back up and if the enemy's
not fast enough it'll recharge but it
recharges much faster if you do this
the cool thing is
if you do it there's certain parts where
you get into like these yokai realms and
if you do that once like perfectly it
gets out without you having to beat the
enemy or it'll like push those yokai
away the yokai being these like uh
the yoke of the germans
um
and then the weapon stance is coming to
play when you're fighting other samurai
and more skill-based enemies because you
can recognize their weapon stance and
know what they're going for and know how
best to counter that if they're in a
high weapon stance you might want to go
low because you know they're going for
damage and slower attacks whereas you
could just dodge around and whittle away
their health
and like miguel had said uh numerous
times in the office and his review in
progress is that there's a really cool
visual style to this game or like a
visual vocabulary that lets you know
what the enemies are going to do more so
than just they're going to telegraph the
attack when they start to wind up yes
but you can also see what stance they're
in and that's going to like uh you know
affect and kind of encourage you to use
a certain stance of your own and let you
read these situations before the monster
actually attacks being able to see their
their stamina as well is super helpful
in a little bit i played today it was
like that automatically made the game
more accessible for me because i knew i
was on
in terms of information on even footing
with my opponent okay yeah i did want to
touch on accessibility because you
brought that up before we started
recording or shooting filming whatever
the word is
live streaming streaming there we go um
i i know things uh just um i think the
other other thing that um appealed to me
is because i'm very intimidated by the
difficult difficulty of souls like games
um but i miguel said this and then other
reviewers also that i read we're talking
about how co-op uh
doesn't like enemies don't scale when
you do co-op um so you can get through a
particularly tough area and like oh it's
like a 15 minute like walking phone a
friend yeah uh walk in the park so like
price is right yeah i do like that you
can lean on that like if you're getting
really frustrated i
i am
i could i can do a good rage quit so i
i'm happy to know that that's available
to me um which also makes it less
intimidating to start playing and then
the tutorials at the beginning and the
information that you get um adds to that
like okay starting this is not going to
be this huge endeavor i don't feel like
i have to take a class to learn how to
play this game i don't have to study it
as much
and then that comes later naturally as
you're playing
another thing in terms of you mentioned
co-op multiplayer-ish area in dark souls
you have people that can invade your
game this has the revenant system so you
come up on what look like bonfires and
dark souls or the sword stuck in the
ground and it's red glowing thing and
when you go near it it shows where
another player died but it also shows
you what they had equipped
so if you see that they had really good
equipment obviously you want to get it
because you in this game you find much
more loot than in dark souls you're not
sticking to one weapon that you're
upgrading yeah i felt like you're four
weapons
yeah you're finding the same samurai
sword just with better stats you're not
finding um
again the kirkhammer and just upgrading
that with blood gems throughout your
you're
finding loot a lot and it's really cool
a risk reward it's like the epitome of
risk reward you see that they have
um like really good equipment which
obviously means they're gonna be harder
to fight though so it's always if you
want to get that equipment that they
have it's if it's worth fighting you're
it's almost always going to be
uh you're out gunned which is cool and
but you don't have to summon them that's
the revenant system um and that's like
how it's a little bit different from
bloodbar and dark souls as well which i
actually really like this because it's a
loot based game so this kind of
encourages you to go for the better loot
by getting to these more difficult
fights um guardian spirits are a big
deal you can pick one that
boosts your stats there's also a skill
tree for this guardian spirits that you
can upgrade them to upgrade your your
heart body skill dexterity i love skill
trees yeah uh and then right now
my guardian spirit that i'm using is
like some sort of bird dragon that
swoops down and hits people and then it
buffs your weapon and you can just hit
in wider attacks and more difficult
attacks
um
and there's like special abilities you
could there's you can upgrade your
samurai abilities by using getting
proficiency with samurai weapons you can
upgrade ninjutsu abilities by using
ninja weapons um and you go into a skill
tree of their own this game is much more
uh
i think in terms of the weapons and the
combat is much more in depth than
bullet-borne and dark souls actually
um which those games have fantastic
would you say much more or just like
more customization okay
there's more customization involved with
your skill trees you can have the
samurai abilities you can have uh you
know three weapon stances as opposed to
the two you can have uh you get more
weapons and then the beginning you pick
like two weapons that you want to be
proficient with i picked the regular
samurai sword and an axe i thought they
balanced each other out well um
and then for another difference you can
uh dark souls have always kind of been
these open world-ish things that are
intersecting in weird ways and then you
can start warping between bonfires as
the game goes on you discover more areas
this game i brought up earlier it's like
a mario map when you go to when you're
actually going the overworld places you
pick
and then once you clear these areas or
maybe not clear because it's like if you
go back to a shrine the shrines are just
like bonfires and dark souls enemies
will regenerate so you can go back and
um
you know farm them for m rita if you
want which is like the souls the upgrade
currency in this game um you once you
clear an area you can go back and do a
twilight mission version which is just
that's like harder
sure it's like a version right it's yeah
the enemies are harder but the loot's
better so it's encouraging you to
retread if you want better loot because
say you can't even go to the vanilla
version this new area when without
better loot have you done much of that
no because my my
question there is like does that get too
grindy or is it necessary to go back and
try to get better loot or can you kind
of get what you need along the way like
that's my remaining question from what
i've heard it can make i don't know if
it can be grindy but it gets really hard
i would assume
yeah grinding is always relative to the
amount of effort you have to put forth
right especially in rpg grinding for me
associated with
just doing rote things yes so far my
experience is you cannot just act in a
rote manner when facing enemies in this
game so
yeah i don't know maybe it's satisfying
even if it is repetitive yeah like if
you're doing the same thing but you
actually have to pay attention to what
you're doing that's less uh
i mean it doesn't have the negative
connotations of repetition sure you know
what i mean yeah feladar in the twitch
chat was calling out my uh mario
comparison how else is this game like
mario
how else
it starts
uh
white man in japan
that is that is accurate oh is mario in
japan is the mushroom king of japan
dinosaur i don't know well he's in new
york in the upcoming mario
odyssey yeah yeah maybe he's not in
japan but
i tried
i didn't really set anybody up for
success with that one
uh but yes
by and large you know it's kind of a low
hanging fruit to talk about how neo
compares to bloodborne dark souls but it
is it's they've been open with the fact
that they're trying to do their own
version of that and i think from what i
played and from what i've heard
it's something that's succeeded yeah
it's really fun so far has it hooks in
me i have the game pop well you can't
pause the game but i have like the
playstation menu up on my desk right now
i hope that pauses it
i was otherwise i'm dead right now i was
always intrigued by how much it reminded
me of onimusha just on a superficial
level yeah but then like the opening cut
scene is almost the opening cut scene
from the original oni musha like the
first thing you see is a crow picking it
flesh which is like
right there and then you see an army and
yeah so there's a lot of if you like
onimusha as well yeah maybe this is your
chance i remember playing ninja gaiden
three was it the last one i played
that's hard as [ __ ] yes this game's hard
for in different ways but
can kill you fast
um
cool i think that's it yeah go play neo
our review will be up later on
this some point this week soon
soon soon very soon so keep an eye on
game spot for our new review from miguel
concepcion we're cutting the video
review today
try to get ready as soon as possible um
and yeah from us three here at the table
it's it's uh got us really interested
and i really like the game so far so go
check it out
from team ninja uh cool and then also
let us know your own thoughts if you've
gotten the chance to play it since
yesterday it released uh mike maherty on
twitter or emma hardy or mma hardy kelly
flag you don't know who you are people
think i'm an mma fighter all the time
i'm uh inky dojiko i-n-k-y d-o-g-i-k-k-o
or just search kelly plaggy if you're in
here
and then peter brown pcb brown p p brown
pc brown pc brown yeah nice i'm gonna
change my handle soon it's fine no i
like it that's good okay
anyway thank you all so much for uh yeah
leaving your thoughts in the chat and uh
like i said hit us up on twitter if you
have any more thoughts on neo if you get
the chance to play it what about hitman
we're gonna talk about hitman
yes
show's not over yet it's not over to
bring this back up it's not over
okay
uh yeah again i just mentioned this at
the beginning of the show if you were
not here
we are giving away three hitman
collectors editions ones for each
platform xbox one pc ps4 this as you can
see
ps4 um gamespot earlier in the show
tweeted um about this so if you don't
follow us on twitter follow us retweet
that exact tweet we'll pick you later on
the week um it comes with
a whole continent
uh the statue of agent 47 kind of
putting a silencer on across like really
casual like full game download the first
season it was an episodic game for those
who don't know last year red tie hitman
clip tie clip uh art book
box
uh we will pick winners later in the
week
we're doing more more giveaways in the
future yeah we do uh pretty much a
giveaway a week now which is good
because we have
a lot of stuff that gets sent here from
various publishers and
studios and whatnot that we want to
share with people um anyway
yeah so that is pretty much our show
today i don't think i'm missing anything
like i said go over to our gamespot
universe side of things to watch that uh
movies are so bad they're good that
should be up now or soon uh pete's in it
rob handler's in it you saw his about
leprechaun four leprechaun in space i
think it's called we didn't have volume
in here if you want to see leprechauns
go up urinal stream uh sorry urethras i
think that's how it works i don't i'm
not a i skipped anatomy when i wasn't
i'm not a doctor not a doctor or an mma
fighter yeah i'm an mma fighter um which
i've had my fair share of
leprechaun fights we will
uh be back next week as always thanks so
much to people in the back jean luc on
the tricaster eric tay richard lee
i think those are the people back there
right now uh and as always we're looking
forward to next week and we will see you
can you hit then uh yep
[Music]